diese Bilder Schrecken auf das war
Nordkosovo im
Mai was ist da los frage ich
mich im September sogar schießereihen
mit toten steht das kleine Junge Land
schon wieder vor einem Krieg wie
99 warum stehen sich im Kosovo Serben
und Albaner so unversöhnlich gegenüber
und warum kocht das ausgerechnet jetzt
hoch ich Reise in den Norden des Kosovo
ich treffe Menschen um das zu
verstehen in switchan sind die
Schmauchspuren der Straßenschlacht noch
zu sehen die Serben hier wollten
verhindern dass ein albanischer
Bürgermeister in das Rathaus einzieht
erzählt mir
vladeta er ist Serbe und arbeitet hier
als
Tennistrainer die Unruhen haben alle
verunsichert erzählt er mir der
Tennisplatz liegt gleich um die Ecke vom
Rathaus
Menschen ziehen weg weil die
Ungewissheit und Unsicherheit groß
sind während wir hier Tennis spielten
standen da hinten die Spezialeinheiten
mit Waffen hier in der
Nähe das macht unsicher wohin soll das
führen und wie lange können wir hier
noch so
leben das überwiegend albanische Kosovo
ist seit 2008 unabhängig Serbien erkennt
das nicht an
im Norden weht deshalb häufig die
serbische Fahne und als Helden verehren
sie hier sogar serbische
Kriegsverbrecher der
90er im Krieg bombardierte schließlich
die NATO Serbien um das Morden an
Albanern zu beenden die NATO gilt vielen
als
Feind vladeta will Kosovos
Eigenständigkeit nicht anerkennen wie
auch sein Idol Novak dokovic dessen
Familie stammt aus San
Kosovo ist Serbien schreibt dokovic da
auf eine Kameralinse dringend notwendige
Unterstützung sei
das er repräsentiert uns Serben die wir
hier leben ob Urgroßvater Kinder bisin
zu dokovic Großvater und
Vater alleben die hier leben glauben
immer noch dass dies ein Teil Serbiens
ist
b die brüe von mit ist das Symbol für K
intung nördlich von hier leben eher
Serben südlich eher Albaner und beide
meinen sie hätten ein Recht aufs Ganze
Kosovo so auch der Albaner Tom batiri
der während des Krieges nach Deutschland
geflüchtet war wir sind hier seit der
sonone wärmt der Erbe wir sind hier 6
bis 8000 Jahre sind wir hier ich habe
gar nicht gegen Serbien aber ich ich
habe weil die mus uns einmal ruhig leben
lassen es gibt Orte wo das Zusammenleben
funktioniert z.B hier in bosatka mahala
zum albanischen burekbäcker waldrin
kommen viele Serben die Dinare die
waldrin mit zeigt belegen das Albaner
nutzen Euros geschäftlich
imben
anders warum die Konflikte zuletzt
wieder so aufgingen wie der buk Teich in
Ihrer Küche dazu braucht es mehrere
Zutaten interne Gründe zum
einen diese Serben müssen sich neue
Kennzeichen holen der junge Staat Kosovo
verlangt das denn statt Serbiens Wappen
auf miroslavs Kennzeichen soll da bald
Kosovos Flagge stehen der junge Staat
Kosovo will seine Autorität nun auch im
Norden durchsetzen ihm sei das egal sagt
Miroslav hauptsache er könne fahren
hinter ihm widerspricht ein junger
Mann mir sind serbische Nummernschilder
lieber lasar meint der Austausch von
Hoheitszeichen sei ein Symbol
kosovoalbanischer
Unterdrückung ich bin Serbe und dies ist
unser Land ein weiteres Symbol die
Rathäuser dort sollten im Mai albanische
Bürgermeister einziehen das hatte
Unruhen ausgelöst die KF musste
eingreifen die Serben hier in Nordkosovo
haben ihre Fahner an die Absperrung
gehängt und im Rathaus im obersten
Stockwerk hat der albanische
Bürgermeister sich verschanzt der
Konflikt ist also noch lange nicht
beigelegt und da wären wir bei den
externen Gründen für die
Konflikte seit letztem Jahr patrullieren
fast keine serbischen Polizisten meh im
Norden das Nachbarland Serbien hatte sie
zum boyott aufgerufen erzählt mir
Leutnant asemi albanische
Grenzpolizisten kommen meist nicht aus
der Gegend Polizisten sind auch Symbol
von Staatlichkeit diese Bilder sollten
die wohl untergraben im Juni wurden drei
Kosovo Polizisten von serbischer Polizei
gekidnappt so die kosovoregierung sie
hätten Grenzen überschritten meint
dagegen der serbische Präsident WS
er will mit dem Thema Kosovo
wahlengwinnen Kosovos Premierminister
Kurti meint wuic provoziere stecke sogar
hinter einem Angriff auf kosowarische
Polizisten beim Kloster Banska mit vier
Toten 30 schwer bewaffnete Serben wurden
angeführt durch einen Vertrauten des
serbischen Präsidenten
wuc der
kam nach Serbien läuft dort frei
herum die Waffen für den Angriff kamen
wohl aus Serbien das da oben auf der
Bergkuppe beginnt die Grenzpolizisten
patroulieren nur noch zu acht und schwer
bewaffnet eigentlich gäbe es kein
Problem mit den Serben im Kosovo meinen
sie wenn nur politische Propaganda und
Hetze nicht
wären es gab Angriffe auf
Polizisten weil die serbische
Gemeinschaft aufgestachelt wird von
kriminellen Gruppen die die kosovoolizei
nicht
akzeptieren es geht darum W im Kosovo
das Sagen hat es geht um Sprache es geht
auch um Religion Serben gehen in die
orthodoxe Kirche Albaner gehen eher in
die
Mosche doch serbischorthodoxen Kloster
VEVO meint Vater vassilie dass auf Erden
die Hölle entstehe wenn Politik die
Religion
missbraucht im Kosovo Krieg erlebte er
grausames als die Klosterkirche
renoviert wurde ließ er deshalb das
Bildnis eines guten Freundes hinzufügen
Vater hariton wurde damals entführt und
später enthauptet
gefunden
seine Entführer trugen albanische
Uniformen dafür gibt es
Beweise aber wir wissen nur eins mit
Sicherheit es waren
Unmenschen beide Seiten waren grausam
aber im Himmelreich gibt es keine
Nationalität sagt vassilie er wünscht
sich dass Politiker das
erkennen wenn sich der Konflikt nun
wieder verschärft wie würde er zB
denbisch
er hör auf
mich dein Herz so vollendet Vater
wasilie den
Satz zeige dass du lieben
kannst doch für den Hass im Kosovo gibt
es auch weltpolitische
Gründe ebenso wie GT Putins Russland den
Serben als
schutzmach westliche und proussische
Propaganda wirkt in Verbindung mit der
serbischen
Sache Kosovo sei für Serbien das was die
Krim für Russland sei steht da und wie
in der Ukraine ist wohl auch hier das
Ziel zu
destabilisieren mit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg wurde proorussische
Propaganda noch einmal verstärkt und sie
wirkt slavissa hat schon vor Jahren
seine Tankstelle mit Putin geschmückt
trotz Angriffskrieg
nicht die Kugel unter Putins Bild
repräsentiert die Welt ich wusste schon
immer dass Putin der Mann sein würde der
alle Probleme der Welt lösen
würde doch das Gegenteil geschieht im
Kosovo verschärft Propaganda die
Konflikte die KFOR wurde deshalb
verstärkt sie soll Puffer sein wenn es
nötig ist aber auch den Austausch
zwischen den vol ermöglich und
zeichenzen die Menschen sollen sich an
unsere Präsenz gewöhnen so wissen Sie
die Amerikaner sind da KF ist da und
kümmert sich das bringt alle mehr
zusammen die KF genießt Vertrauen bei
allen im Kosovo so eine Studie trotzdem
gilt die NATO die sie stellt vielen
Serben als Feind der regionale
Kommandeur zeigt sich davon betont
unbeeindruckt manches davon soll nur
aufrühren und es sind vielleicht nur
Operationen unter falscher Flagge ich
kann Ihnen versichern dass die täglichen
Begegnungen die wir haben mit echten
Menschen auch sehr positiv sind es wird
auch von anderen von außen Einfluss
ausgeübt ich denke es gibt Belege für
den Einfluss anderer Leute die NATO
reagiert Mitte November reist
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg durch den
Balkan schüttelt Hände fordert Dialog
und Kompromiss
und setzt
Zeichen nach den Gewaltausbrüchen hat
NATO rund 1000 peacekeepers und schwere
Waffen in das Kosovo geschickt das ist
die größte Verstärkung unserer Kosovo
Truppen in 10 Jahren und es zeigt dass
NATO bereit ist den Frieden zu
bewahren es lohnt sich für das Vaterland
zu sterben steht da mehr als 20 Jahre
nach dem Krieg überwiegt im Kosovo die
hen vereirrung und weniger die
Erinnerung an Leid und Tod erzählt die
Serbin Jovana
radosblwit sie fürchtet dass Kriege
anderswo auch hier Gewalt rechtfertigen
könnten und internationale
Aufmerksamkeit ablenken schlecht für das
Kosovo ihre NGO will Albaner und Serben
eininander näher bringen da helfen schon
kleine instaosts zu gemeinsamen Worten
wieapi die Politik treibe die Menschen
mit Absicht
auseinander es hängt wirklich von den
politischen Machthabern ab wenn sie nur
wollen können Sie Berge versetzen das
Problem ist dass die Regierungschefs in
beiden Hauptstädten am Berge versetzen
kein Interesse haben kein Interesse an
den Bedürfnissen der Menschen hier es
geht ihn nur um den eigenen politischen
Gewinn wir dagegen sind in ein Art
Vorhölle nirgends richtig
[Musik]
angekommen der Konflikt der oben
angeheizt wird kommt unten bis an die
Kleinsten heran Roter Stern Belgrad ist
sein Team und natürlich will jeder Junge
in vladetas Tennistraining der nächste
Novak dokovt sein und das heißt
[Musik]
auch jedes Kind will für Mutter Serbien
spielen für das Land in dem sie geboren
wurden und in dem sie
leben unter welcher Flagge ihr
sportlicher Erfolg steht den kleinen ist
das wohl noch relativ egal es sind die
großen die Wege finden müssen den Stolz
nicht mit Hass und Konflikt zu
verbinden